tell me about the growth that you went
through from that shell of a guy that i
talked about earlier um you know in that
video where you're like what did you say
in that video exactly because i mean
obviously you made it so you know
exactly what happened what you stated so
can you talk about that and sort of like
yeah like the storyline arc you know
between then and now
for sure yeah i think the video you're
referring to was a video i talked about
the separation with my wife i think i
titled it why my wife left me because
i've always been a pretty good marketer
so i knew that would get a lot of
attention you know
uh
and
i actually took that video i don't do
this anymore and maybe i had to revisit
that but i took that video down because
so many a-holes just misinterpreted what
i was saying and i just i didn't want to
get in the bull crap of them trying to
you know
paint me as a beta or a cuck or all
these terms you know people throw around
but you know admittedly i was in that
camp that you just said earlier of
playing not to not to lose
um and and i was just trying to like
grasp on to some semblance of my life
before my wife left me and frankly at
the time a lot of my universe revolved
around her you know i didn't realize
that until she left uh and took my
one-year-old son at the time um oh it
was just the one child that you had just
one at the time yeah we have four now we
have four now but it was just one at the
time okay uh and so for a long time man
i really blamed her i was like how could
she do this why was she disloyal she
didn't appreciate you know what i was
doing and what i'm trying to grow my
business for the family
and
i remember i was driving down the road
and i came to the conclusion so we're
knee-deep in our separation that holy
[ __ ] maybe
maybe this isn't like just her
maybe there's like maybe i have
something to do with it
uh and i i had just at that point
written off the marriage thinking this
thing was over and at that point it was
very cathartic for me because i went to
work on myself
i started to get into shape i started
dialing my finances my business started
growing i started getting back into some
spiritual elements of my life that i had
let go
i i built new friendships i hired her
mentor like i was kicking ass
and it was like flipping a switch on the
wall you know she she responded to that
she saw that
and and i came to this conclusion that
you know we can't control people which
is what i was trying to do like if she
did this and she did that and i just
needed her to change then my life would
be great
and i moved from hey i'm not going to
try to control people anymore i'm going
to live my life the way i want to live
it i'm going to do the best i can the
way i see fit and then i'm going to have
faith that that's gonna influence people
in my life positively her my kids um
people that might be inspired by what
we're doing here and so i i've i've i've
let go of that the need to like change
people and
prove to people like what they should do
i'm just going to shine as a beacon to
the best of my ability and let the chips
fall where they may um and that's proved
to be instrumental not only in my
marriage but in the business and in the
movement as well what's the like what
was the catalyst that caused you guys to
part ways at that time
uh you know i don't think it was just
one thing i remember we got into a fight
one evening about who knows what i don't
even remember uh and
i said i remember this i vividly
remember this i said i don't even want
to be married to you anymore
and she said i agree i don't either
and the next morning uh i was supposed
to go
four hours north for some training in my
business and i got about an hour north
like man what the hell are you doing and
i turned around and came home and i was
like hey look like yeah obviously this
is not what i believe but then it was
too little too late
then she was gone um i just think there
was a lot of contention and animosity
that had built up in a relationship i
spent some time overseas with the
military and when i got back we had only
been married for six months when i left
and when i got back it was like trying
to
like date again but we were married and
then i was trying to grow my financial
planning practice
and i was frustrated because
i didn't know how to do it and i felt
inadequate and i was overweight and out
of shape i was a loser man
and i took all of that frustration out
on the person whose fault or
responsibility it wasn't my wife was my
responsibility and i didn't pin that on
myself i pinned it on her and then i
played these little manipulation games
and made her feel like [ __ ] that that
had something to do with her um so you
know that boiled over that evening and
uh man that was a dark time in my life
it really was
it was it was very obvious in that video
like i
i don't have a copy because you took it
down but i vividly remember thinking to
myself wow this guy's like hit the
bottom
yeah man you know he's gonna keep
digging down or is he gonna you know
climb his way out of this one
um and it sounds like you did something
with all that hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you